later on today we're going to be
speaking with political scientist rachel
bittikoffer and one of the questions
that i will have for rachel is
are the numbers that increasingly
suggest this might not be a disastrous
midterm for democrats are they numbers
that can be trusted because we're
getting more and more of these numbers
now you might remember that last week or
the week before maybe it was
i told you that for the first time in
this primary season
in the 538 forecast for the u.s senate
democrats became favored to retain
control now it was a very small margin
it was 52 to 48 meaning if you run a
hundred simulations with the current
inputs
in 52 of them democrats end up
controlling the senate and in 48 of them
republicans end up controlling the
senate
um
we this is sort of like if you had a
coin that instead of being a 50 50 coin
was a 52 48 coin meaning the more times
you flip it the closer you'll get to 52
heads and 48 tails now if you only flip
it once it's either going to be heads or
tails and 52 to 48 is a very very small
margin in favor of heads but the the
more times you run the simulation the
closer to 52 you will get that's the
idea here
those numbers have now grown to 57
in the exact same 538 forecast and in
fact nate silver put together an article
on 538 which you can check out which has
a bunch of different data the article
from a few days ago called the political
environment might be improving for
democrats and indeed when you look at
how the senate forecast has changed if
you looked in at the beginning of june
democrats only had about a 40 to 45
percent shot at holding the senate
remember democrats currently have the
senate 50 50 with the vice president
kamala harris as the tie-breaking vote
in the event of a 50-50 tie those
numbers have increased increased
increased to where now
it is a 57
chance that democrats
control the senate after the midterm
elections and only a 43 percent chance
that republicans control it now as we
know
even things that are statistically
unlikely
sometimes happen going into the 2016
presidential election the odds were
that hillary clinton had an 85 percent
chance of winning and donald trump had a
15 chance of winning now 85 percent is
not a hundred percent you run a hundred
simulations in 15 of them trump would
come out the winner and indeed he did
this is a very very small margin but we
have to it's not even really come to
terms with it's understand that there's
a unique or at least an unlikely an
uncommon opportunity this november
normally and i know you guys or some of
you are sick of hearing this normally
when one party takes the white house
in the first midterm election
they lose the house and or senate or if
they already don't have control of the
house they fall even further behind or
if they have control of the house and
retain it it's by a smaller margin you
get the point
we might not see that this november
and
if the question is why which is to me
the most interesting question
right now everything we know everything
we can say
is that it's because primarily
of two issues number one abortion and
number two gun safety although i have to
say
compared to six eight weeks ago the gun
safety issue is not nearly in the
forefront as much as it was but we have
two issues that normally are not good
issues for democrats to run on
that are helping democrats right now the
country mostly wants abortion to be
legal in most cases we saw that on
tuesday night in kansas
where kansas voters
voted to defeat an amendment which would
have allowed completely banning abortion
they voted to defeat that amendment by a
20-point margin that is not a small
margin and that's a very red state one
of the reddest states in the country
and when roe v wade was overturned by
the supreme court
even many centrists and center right
people said that this is wrong this is
wrong abortion should be legal in most
cases and that may not help republicans
in november in fact it could be their
undoing and in addition to that although
i think it's diminishing compared to a
couple of months ago
continued mass shootings
and just absurd reactions from
republicans oh it's the issue is doors
arm teachers put more guns in the
schools ballistic backpacks and uh bob
grenade resistant blankets or whatever
it was that was being proposed
outrageous and although there are still
many millions of true believers who
think the solution here is morrigan
certainly not to restrict access to guns
more and more of the country
supports all sorts of common sense
gun safety regulations we've looked at
the numbers overwhelming support for
background checks in all cases even
personal transfers and sales gun show
every every situation there should be a
background check and i've given you the
list but our elected officials by and
large don't support these things at
least not the republican party this
really seems to be hurting republicans
and this is why now in what should be
a really big defeat i mean by all
historical assessments democrats should
get crushed in november
it's increasingly looking if we had to
just say what's the most mathematically
likely scenario the most likely scenario
is democrats lose the house but not by
much
and democrats maintain control of the
senate now it might not go that way we
all must vote we must get involved we
must phone bank all of the things right
we're going to be talking about them
because it could come down to one race
in the senate it really could come down
to one race
um we are going to continue talking
about it but the inevitable massive red
wave that many had been touting for a
long time since joe biden was sworn in
that massive red wave seems increasingly
unlikely
many of you have emailed me and said
david herschel walker has finally agreed
to a debate against rafael warnock and i
looked at the video and i have to tell
you i don't think rafael warnock is
going to debate herschel walker i don't
really think herschel walker has agreed
to anything when you listen closely to
the video it seems as though he is
putting in place all sorts of conditions
and obstacles but let me back up before
we look at the video what the hell am i
talking about herschel walker won his
republican primary race in georgia for
the senate
now walker will face incumbent
democratic senator raphael warnock one
of the real question marks has been
since herschel walker cannot speak
how could he possibly debate during the
republican primary herschel walker did
not debate and he easily sailed to
victory basically riding on
the wave of uh celebrity
and to some degree probably trump's
endorsement in georgia
so
now the question is again coming up is
herschel walker going to debate raphael
warnock and as i've told you before
herschel walker we don't know if it's
some combination of
cte from playing football chronic
traumatic encephalopathy
um
mental illness
uh
whatever we don't know what he really
cannot express himself he can't explain
his positions on issues he often is
completely unable to use words to
assemble meaning and communicate it in
the english language he just can't speak
and there's been a real question as to
how is how is this guy possibly going to
debate the headlines a couple of days
ago were
walker has agreed to a debate he's going
to debate rafael warnock
let's look at two videos
i don't think he's going to debate
rafael warnock here is walker on the
sean hannity fox news propaganda program
listen to what he says will you debate
rafael warnock
well i'm going to open this up on your
show
right now i have accepted a debate in
savannah georgia in his backyard that we
can debate october the 14th
in front of a crowd that it'll be his
people because we're in his backyard and
this debate is going to be about the
people it's not about some political
party it's not about the press but the
people need to see the differences
between senator warnock and herschel
walker and what i mean by that they're
going to see that as you just said
georgia don't want high gas prices well
he voted against the pipeline georgia
want to protect our men and women in
blue well he called them names he called
them thugs georgia don't want men and
women sports where he voted to put men
in women's sports where it is time that
people see the difference so in october
the 14th i want senator warnock to be
ready because i've accepted a debate
then now he can quit talking and show
the people that he's going to stand
behind his words and show up for the
debate okay
so october 14th we don't actually know
that that's a date that's been proposed
or agreed to with rafael warnock
with a crowd
i mean okay so so that's another
condition
it will be a debate about the people not
about a party or the media
so does that mean that rafael warnock
and
herschel walker
can't have a moderator what exactly is
it that herschel walker is saying it's
all kind of weird and it feels pretty
soft and squishy so then herschel walker
did another video
this was very clearly by the way this
was very clearly read off of some kind
of teleprompter and this was the best
take that they got and again it's not
really sounding to me like herschel
walker is actually going to debate
anybody listen to this i don't wanna
i'm ready to debate
in fact i just accepted a debate in your
backyard so it's the same talking point
i accepted a debate in your backyard
okay but has one been arranged what does
that mean you've accepted it
where you got home field advantage and
it's going to be broadcast statewide
i'm not a politician
i don't look like a politician i don't
sound like a politician
and frankly i'm tired a politician okay
so i'm not going to obey the demands of
the elite press and the liberty
establishment to stand in an empty room
for the debate so to me i'm hearing
if it's a normal debate where there will
be moderators and like some control of
the crowd
walker won't do it that's what i'm
hearing and quite frankly
it's very difficult to imagine that his
campaign advisors would allow him to
debate i mean
i understand why he's not debating
because it would be a disaster
that's supposed to be about the people
you see
i don't answer to the press
and i don't answer to rafael why not
i don't answer anyone but god
and the people of georgia so what god
has to moderate i mean it's he he's
giving himself so many outs here so i
accepted a debate
that's about voters
i'm leaving the immediate elite behind
and taking my message right to the
people so it sounds like basically he
wants it to be a rally
i mean do we know that herschel walker
knows what a debate is in the political
space like what they look like so they
can see the difference
between the two of us
october the 14th
in savannah
senator warnock i hope to see you there
yeah so that's the best take they were
able to get and i mean listen
i have to tell you
if this guy becomes a senator over
raphael warnock
it would be even
more
destructive in what it means about
what's going on in the united states i
mean
trump can at least
speak this guy doesn't understand a
single issue any and he can't speak and
then you look at someone like rafael
warnock who understands issues can
explain his perspective clearly and
decisively and in a way that connects to
the english language
if voters vote for herschel walker and
make him one of 100 u.s senators
i already think things are sort of in
the toilet in the united states to some
degree politically but it would be like
a 10 to 15 flusher let's put it that way
if herschel walker is able to win so i
hope he debates i don't believe that
this is him really being committed to a
debate
and i think his advisors would be crazy
to allow him to debate let me know what
you think are we going to see him in an
actual debate with raphael warnock find
me on twitter at deepakman we'll take a
quick break and be right back
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
we are going to look today at one of the
most remarkable pieces of video that i
have ever seen in the entire time i have
been doing this show
and you all know we've seen a lot of
outrageous video in the middle of alex
jones defamation trial it is the award
phase during which a jury is to decide
how much money should the plaintiffs get
for having been defamed by infowars
conspiracy theorist alex jones it was
revealed that alex jones own incompetent
lawyer
sent a digital copy of all of alex jones
text messages and phone communications
to the plaintiff's lawyers i really need
people to understand how insane this is
alex jones for the last 10 12 14 days
however long this phase of the trial has
been going on
has been
lying
and making claims like i never did any
texting about sandy hook which is the
subject matter of the defamation trial
and all along the plaintiff's council
had
knowledge
that alex jones was lying he did text
about sandy hook and the reason the
lawyer knew it is alex jones lawyer
mistakenly sent him all of the records
and yesterday during the trial it came
out this video going instantly viral do
you know what perjury is
becoming the line of the day you have to
see this so you did get my text messages
and they said you did
nice trick
yes mr johnson indeed yes mr jones
indeed
you didn't give this text message to me
you don't you don't know where this came
from do you know where i got this no
mr jones
did you know that 12 days ago 12 days
ago
your attorneys messed up and sent me an
entire digital copy of your entire cell
phone with every text message you've
sent for the past two years and when
informed
did not take any steps to identify it as
privileged or protected in any way
and as of two days ago it fell free and
clear into my possession this is this is
one of the best things that has ever
happened during a trial i've seen that
is how i know you lied to me when you
said you didn't have text messages about
it and this is the moment that alex
jones soul leaves his body you can see
it exit at the 47 second mark in this
video
did you know that
i see i told you the truth this is your
perry mesa moment i gave them my phone
and then mr jones you need to answer the
question
no i don't know this happened but i mean
i told you i gave them the phone over
and just said well justin
you said in your deposition
you searched your phone
you said you pulled down the text did
the search function for sandy hook
that's what you said mr jones correct
and i had several several different
phones with this number but i did yeah
i mean that's why you got it
the pretzel that alex jones is twisting
himself into is really something else
here
my lawyer said it to you but i'm hiding
it okay mr jones
mr joseph just answered questions
there's no question
mr benson also only asked questions sure
mr jones in discovery you were asked do
you have sandy hook text messages on
your phone and you said no correct
you said that under oath
didn't you i mean mistaken i was
mistaken but you've got the messages
right there you know what perjury is
right
i just want to make sure you know before
we go any further you know what it is
yes i do i mean i'm not a tech guy i
told you i gave in my testimony the
phone to the lawyers before whatever and
and so you've got my phone but we didn't
give it to you no mr jones one more time
and please remember if you need to
assert the amendment you can i need to
know that you can do that
but you test them
if you need to plead the fifth here then
you're able to do that which of course i
mean it's a strategy as well because
that if all of a sudden he asserts the
fifth amendment even though of course
strictly speaking that cannot be used in
order to indicate guilt or
responsibility it's certainly not going
to look very good
i have no idea how plaintiff's council
did not
i don't know how plaintiff's council was
able to go two weeks
without
the biggest s eating grin on his face as
alex jones tells lie after lie
knowing that he has the records already
he waited until the perfect moment and
he dropped it like he had been planning
this his entire life
it's very difficult to imagine a more
humiliating and public implosion than
this and then also during during
yesterday's uh testimony
um alex jones was confronted about the
fact that during the trial he's been
broadcasting images of the judge on fire
and that's also just another incredible
moment look at this
the person on the left of this image is
our judge correct
yes the person on the right is another
judge you don't like right yes okay
one of the things you can think of
one of the things you've been talking
about a lot recently on your show
uh even within the past couple months
is your allegation
that government officials
are aiding in pedophilia
child trafficking and the grooming of
children he's basically being confronted
with pizzagate as applied to the judge
in a court of law while under oath
what do you mean like what jeffrey
epstein did with the cleanse
sure if that's a yes is that a yes yes
okay
and on thursday
you and infowars started connecting
those allegations to our judge didn't he
no
in fact mr jones you're telling the
world
not to believe
what happens in this courtroom
because the judge
worked with child protective services
who you say
is involved with pedophilia and child
trafficking correct
not all of it but it's the texas youth
commission got caught doing it a lot
there's been a lot of that here i'm not
asking you that mr jones i'm asking you
you're telling imagine if every time
these right-wing nuts lied
they were subjected to under oath
cross-examination of their claims i mean
trump would have no campaign the world
not to believe what's happened in this
trial because this judge
is involved with cps who is working with
child traffickers in pedophilia correct
by the way if you're not watching
the look on the judge's face as alex
jones is being questioned about his
claims about this very judge i have
never seen anything like this no that's
not what i'm saying okay your honor at
this time we would like to show a clip
from mr jones show on thursday where
those words are set up
for impeachment first engagement
purposes yes
all right so now they get into you know
alex jones lawyer tries to exclude the
video that they want to play and
ultimately they do play it this is
unlike anything i have ever seen a
massive public humiliation for alex
jones and in this next segment we are
going to look at when the subject of the
money finally comes up
so one of the things that's at issue in
the alex jones defamation trial award
phase
is alex jones claim of bankruptcy now
alex jones is not bankrupt however alex
jones has filed for bankruptcy and he
has even admitted that part of it is in
order to shield or protect certain
assets from the potential settlement
that is coming uh the potential award
that is coming for the defamatory
statements that alex jones made
one of the things alex jones tried to do
during his testimony is to claim i am
bankrupt and the judge actually directed
him to stop saying that that he is not
bankrupt that he may have filed for
bankruptcy but that he is not bankrupt
and he can't continue to say that
yesterday judge maya guerra gamble uh
actually talked to alex jones about what
sort of a settlement do you believe
would be fair
and alex jones trying to beg for mercy
saying even two million dollars would
sink info wars now that's sort of hard
to believe given that it's on record
that infowars would sometimes make 800
000 in a single day but check out this
incredible exchange
what compensation would you believe to
be appropriate
what compensation do i think appropriate
despite these numbers that were
presented the best week we ever had
that's when kobe was starting
and
there was a run on historical food
nationwide
uh and so they
mr jones
i'm just saying we don't we're speaking
about association would you believe to
be appropriate it doesn't really matter
about that i understand but i can answer
the question however i wish i'm not
borrowed from talking about where we're
at financially no you are at this stage
right now the question is what
compensation would be appropriate
any compensation above
two million dollars will
sink us and
we'll be shut down no appropriate not to
you
appropriate for what happened to them i
mean i mean i think it's appropriate for
whatever whatever you decide you want to
do
because i'm not really
that's a great answer thank you
this was just like i've never seen
anything like this and again the
question is based on the acts what do
you believe is appropriate and alex
jones is saying
we can't afford anything over two
million dollars which also by the way
seems to be a lie one of the other
things that's been going on and then
we're gonna go to a break and we're
gonna get back to a little bit of this
later actually one of the other things
that's been going on is that again while
the trial has been taking place on his
program alex jones has been saying
things about
the trial the judge and the jury
and um the judge also making an effort
there to uh probably to prevent a
mistrial or subsequent appeal by asking
direct questions about the members of
the jury are you aware that this jury
consists of 16 intelligent fair-minded
citizens who are not being improperly
influenced in any way
yes i don't think that you are
operatives i don't think that you are
part of a false flag
even alex jones no matter where he goes
in life he can't get away from this
false flag operative stuff he's now in a
defamation trial and he has to clarify
he's not saying the jurors are part of a
false flag you are bad people i think
you're good people and
i just am very very critical about
the whole process that i've been through
so far
where i've given i believed everything
over
and then i'm always told we didn't even
know we're seeing it and so that's why
i'm really concerned uh because a lot
has been misrepresented
do you feel you're getting a fair trial
and if not why not
but
i'm bored from saying succinctly please
i have been found guilty by a judge
and i fought in america you're found
guilty by juries
there's no guilty or innocence in civil
court
[Laughter]
you couldn't write something i mean this
is just unbelievable i understand liable
or not not guilty so please don't use
that and you're not a lawyer that's fine
okay well
i've been found liable
okay so by a judge and and and
in all the other cases coming up have
already been found so
this is a dangerous new system they're
setting up and if people want to get rid
of that and get rid of america it's okay
i understand we're an old republic maybe
time for us to go get rid of america if
alex jones has to pay up because of the
things that he said
it's the end of america folks incredible
unprecedented and just dozens and dozens
of emails from people in the audience
pouring in about this insanity
and we'll get back to a couple other
elements of it a little bit later in the
show if you're curious about what these
clips look like and you're just
listening today you'll be able to find
these clips on our instagram david
pakman show find us there
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpakmanshow it's great
to welcome back to the program today
rachel bittikoffer who's an election
forecaster and analyst host of the
podcast the election whisperer as well
as the founder of strike pack rachel
always great having you on thank you
yeah and david i have to update my bio
because i left strike pack in april and
uh do independent work now okay well we
will make that change we will update
that so listen um you know usually
there's this conventional wisdom
uh when democrats run on issues like
abortion and gun safety it doesn't do
anything to get democrats out to vote
but it angers republicans it gets
republicans out to vote against
democrats and yet when we look at the
polling over the last two months it
seems as though
talking about roe v wade and talking
about republican inaction on gun safety
is actually activating the democratic
base and all of a sudden the numbers are
not looking as bad for democrats as they
typically would in the first midterm
after winning the white house is that an
accurate assessment or am i missing
something
no i mean no i'm gonna say it's not i'm
gonna say there's some things that i
would push back on there okay
i mean there is a perception right and
i'm sure the progressive left is used to
hearing this um excuse as to why
cultural issues have not been focused on
in democratic campaigns this idea of
cross-mobilization right like you're
trying to mobilize your own base but all
you do is motivate the other one that
there's absolutely no data to support
that assertion and i have tried to prove
it quantitatively before so it's really
important for people to understand that
you know if the republican party has
been fed that kind of messaging for
years and it doesn't necessarily
motivate us what motivates us is a fear
or threat catalyst so when we look at
what happened in kansas last night i
started talking once the memo leaked for
the row evisceration so if that if that
memo comes to fruition and they um you
know repeal row and all these abortion
laws go into effect their gop is going
to be able to ban you know total
abortion ban in the places they have
trifecta control what we're going to see
is is a
potentially
something so strong and so um
catastrophic in the body politic that
you could see a momentum change from the
fundamental midterms of midterm
fundamentals that are against the in
party right and so what we saw initially
was spontaneous
protest pop up everywhere that was a
really good data sign something similar
to what we saw in 2017 and 2018 when we
saw the trump effect coming and then of
course kansas is our first election
since then it was of course heavily
focused on it was the only thing on the
ballot so it's really important for
people to understand that abortion um
salience from from rho is a product in
kansas is a product of it being heavily
focused on so it's really important
people focus on it it's not gonna be
some residual effect that they can tap
into without trying to harvest it and uh
it's based on negative partisanship
people are
people are active our side especially
when they feel threatened and when biden
got elected a lot of people rolled back
that fear and now it's back
and so when you look at the 538 senate
forecast for example which is kind of
ticked up and up where now it says
democrats have a 57 chance of holding
the senate that is the result of exactly
the factors you just listed
yes these are quantitative metrics so i
put out i mean if you follow me
regularly on twitter and i recommend you
do and just read my thread because it's
really where i do most of my my analysis
these days because of time limitations
um you'll see that i start talking about
midterm effects the midterm in the
four-year presidential term always hurts
the in party because the in party is the
one getting all the bad headlines right
especially faces a dishonest opposition
right and so um when we talked about the
midterm effect i said listen there's
been two interruptions in the midterm
effect both of those were times when the
national conversation got disrupted uh
and the most recent was 2002 with bush
because keep in mind he was seeded into
the presidency of a very very large
controversy and was not popular until 9
11. right and so that midterm would have
been bruising for republicans and
instead they gained seats so i started
talking about you know look if we're
gonna we can't just bear our heads in
the stand and pretend that fundamentals
don't matter so let's try to move the
mechanisms that move the midterm effect
and
one you know those are that's about
national referendum on the republican
party and we really are starting to see
the system um you know resonate those
changes in data so in 2002 like you say
at the time of the midterms the
president had a high approval rating as
a result of 9 11. right now joe biden
has a very low approval rating i went
back and looked it looks like you have
to go back to 19 1946 or 45 when a
president at this point in their first
term had this low in approval rating it
was truman is the expectation that with
biden at 37 percent that that will
specifically hurt democrats in november
or have the have the two become
disaggregated to some degree now versus
20 years ago
oh absolutely disaggregated and every
time somebody tells me oh i did a
cross-time analysis where it was like
this in 1993 and i'm like yeah dude
because polarization is not it's not
some buzzword it's a quantifiable
behavioral characteristic that manifests
in behavior across elites the mass
public politicians media system and it
has caused it has really um disrupted
the ability to look back in time and
make comparisons because let me explain
why biden's approval rating is so low
and also lower than donald's trump
donald trump's when any objective
assessment would definitely tell you
which of these two presidencies were
more controversial turbulent um and the
reason is because hyper partisanship and
polarization is asymmetrical it affects
the right side of the isle war which is
why the republican party is having a
flirt with fascism moment here and one
of the ways that it manifests is tribal
allegiance so when whatever happened
with donald trump no matter how bad the
headline was that week his approval
rating was stagnant it was a flat line
that should never happen in a healthy
democracy okay and once you started to
see inelastic presidential approval you
start to realize okay i'm measuring
latent partisanship in the electorate
and not actual objectivity so what you
see with biden and why he's worse than
trump guys you're gonna love this is
because progressive democrats are
willing to tell pollsters that they're
dissatisfied with what the
administration's been able to get done
so you actually see an 80 20 partisan
split on approval for democrats versus
what you might see in 90 95
10 for donald trump
if uh so
i don't really make economic predictions
but just in taking a look at different
indicators it seems to me that next
tuesday we're going to get an inflation
number for july that's significantly
lower than that from june there's going
to be the ability for democrats to
accurately talk about the economy is
looking better as we get into november
with the three months that remain
between now and the midterm elections is
there an opportunity to get back to
talking about the economy uh will it
will it make a difference is that what
democrats should do if indeed inflation
starts declining and the the numbers
look better
i mean here's the thing is and i talk
about this a lot there's three issues
that are going to dominate the midterm
in terms of the availability of issues
to affect things which is mostly low
coalitional turnout but also conversion
pool that 10 or 15 percent of pure
independents who can be
affected are going to be affected by the
national atmosphere
and so what i've said with democrats is
you know the republican party voted on
mass against the one piece of
legislation we were able to put on the
floor to lower inflation so you wedge
that and you just hit them over the head
with one
theme they had a chance to act against
inflation and what did they do they put
politics over you
is there any senate race right now
that you consider to be
any kind of bellwether in a sense or are
the things that are happening for
example in the walker warnock race in
georgia completely unrelated to what's
happening with like oz fetterman in
pennsylvania or like what are you what
are you looking at in terms of specific
races
well i mean we've got a really
interesting scenario when it look when
we think about oz and uh walker i mean
both of these are are really
tremendously weak candidates
so that i mean
i think
pennsylvania was always going to be a
toss-up and maybe advantage fetterman
against a normal nominee and then
luckily it's not it's a product of a bad
nominee and also what the fetterman
campaign is doing with the clay that
they have okay so getting a bad nominee
is one thing getting making use of that
and
and using it as an effective branding
weapon against your opponent is another
okay and so the reason we're seeing such
good numbers out of georgia and
pennsylvania right now is because both
of those campaigns went aggressive
especially the outside groups too
um in the case of georgia on branding
the opponent and and and creating
a disqualified you know disqualification
effect and that's really what democrats
have to do in in this midterm so
normally you know you might look at
republicans and be like okay you know
inflation's high they're not offering
you inflation um solutions right they
run against one thing and that is
democrats are socialists that want to
turn your men child into women and we're
going to save you from there right so
like when we think about
so you think about inflation and what
that party is offering they are so weak
on the economy that it should not be
hard at all for democrats to disqualify
change and so when i talk about
messaging on economy on a dum on
democracy rights freedom and abortion
which all tie in i'm really talking
about messaging that is focused squarely
on the republican party making sure
people understand what that party looks
like today how crazy and dangerous it is
for them personally the asymmetrical uh
aspect to this between republicans and
democrats
seems almost like scarily present in the
walker versus warnock race because i
mean walker can barely explain a single
position like he can't he the guy can
barely speak and we've talked before
like is it cte from football is it
there's all these different things okay
you can speculate about he can't
articulate his position on any issue and
yet he's only losing by like eight or
nine points or something like that which
just shows the completely different
standards that republicans have for who
they're willing to vote for
oh exactly yeah no i mean here's the
thing once you get late in partnership
so like no one's paying attention to
this stuff right now that we know about
so you know once once the campaign
actually gets going in september and the
like the rest of the marginal voting
population gets brought into the
conversation
actually what you're going to see is a
vote share probably will go up not down
dude and that's because a lot i mean it
is you know they voted for a obvious
child predator in alabama 90 10 in that
special election that doug jones won and
doug jones won it okay but he did not
win it because republicans rejected a
child predator he
won it because of a sort of of massive
turnout and black vote and black voter
turnout and um you know a little bit of
conversion pull pull off that was a kind
of like a perfect storm that allowed him
to do it but if they'll put
him in the senate this man that that had
a new york you know 11 accusations of
being a child predator they'll put
anybody in there doesn't matter because
what their job what they care about now
is seizing power and then using it to
crush us so let's talk a little bit in
the last few minutes we have about the
way in which 22 may impact 24
specifically for trump and biden there's
the idea that depending on how trump
endorsed and maga people do in 2022 it
will impact whether trump tries to be
the nominee in 24. another perspective
is trump's going to try because he
thinks it'll keep him out of legal
trouble so there's like the trump side
of things on the biden side
i've never really felt biden it planned
to run for re-election in 24 i just
don't think he's doing it i don't think
he ever really wanted to jenn saki from
the get-go would say joe biden intends
to run and then when kamala harris said
he's running the next day she walked it
back and said his intention is so i just
i just don't think he's running for
reelection
how does what happens in 22
impact the potential candidacies of
either of those two people
i mean i can tell you these two
elections roll together guys if we do
not show up in large numbers and defend
democracy here in 22 then we stand
potentially lose the governorships no
matter how bad the candidates are in
michigan and pennsylvania if we were to
lose either one of those then we'd lose
the blue wall the big three and that's
the big three that hits 270. so we can
lose georgia we can lose arizona okay
and we may well lose those to fascist
republicans if people vote but at the
end of the day
like we cannot lose michigan and
pennsylvania or we do not have a
guarantee of a free and fair election
at all for 2024. i mean imagine a newly
minted republican governor of michigan
do you think they're going to be on the
side of democracy or outside fascism
right i'm going with fascism
what do you think about the biden 24
thing have you given any thought to it
you know here's what i would say is if
he doesn't plan on running he doesn't
act like that to me he's as cautious as
any traditional first-term president
which is you know if i had to offer a
criticism
to the administration it would be that
this is this is a moment for churchill
not chamberlain we need winston
churchill in the in
posturally in that leadership position
we need somebody to speak very frankly
headed into 22 about the stakes of this
election what's on the ballot across
these 50 states and and uh state
legislatures and and federal house
elections because you know at the end of
the day he's got the bully pulpit nobody
else has that bully pulpit and i
honestly think
whether his intends to run or not that
would serve him best politically too but
right now you don't question that his
plan is to run for reelection
i i just don't bother speculating about
stuff like that right now david i'm
really focused on trying to keep
democracy from falling into a fascist
pit fair that's a good that's a good
thing to focus on i would say actually
uh we've been speaking speaking with
rachel bittikoffer election forecaster
analyst the podcast is the election
whisper rachel always a pleasure having
you on thank you
yeah thank you so much and if you don't
mama plug my new book that is going to
be coming out 2023 by crown and it's
called hit him hit him where it hurts
how to be how to save democracy by
beating republicans at their own game
well i'm sure we'll have you on to talk
about it when the book is out yeah for
sure thank you rachel
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick tock
all right i know there's been a lot of
alex jones stuff on today's program but
it really is an incredible situation now
as if things aren't already looking bad
enough for infowars conspiracy theorist
alex jones after getting caught lying
yesterday in cord and all of these other
things we are now learning that as a
result of what has come out in the
defamation trial the january 6 committee
is planning to subpoena alex jones this
is an exclusive from rolling stone
january 6 committee prepares to subpoena
alex jones texts and emails jones
lawyers in a sandy hook defamation case
fumbled three years worth of texts and
emails the committee would like to know
more about any contacts with donald
trump's team regarding the january 6th
capital attack this is uh oh and i'm not
logged in and we're not even going to
deal with that right now i have another
article about this january 6th panel set
to subpoena alex jones after revelations
in defamation trial the january 6 select
committee is reportedly planning to
subpoena far-right conspiracy theorist
alex jones after his texts and emails
were revealed wednesday in a defamation
lawsuit filed by sandy hook shooting
victim families in a cross-examination
sandy hook victim's attorney mark
bankston told jones his lawyer
erroneously sent bankston three years
worth worth of the conspiracy theorists
emails and text messages copied from his
phone the january six select committee
is now reportedly preparing to request
those records from the attorneys
representing the sandy hook victims to
investigate the deadly capital
insurrection this is just unbelievable
going from bad to worse for alex jones
and jones has managed to keep himself
more or less isolated from the january
6th committee probe
uh that appears to be ending at this
point in time and it would not shock me
i mean listen at this point i'm glad all
of this is happening this it genuinely
genuinely seems like this is what alex
jones deserves if we want to talk about
about
merit
but
alex jones must be considering do i fire
my attorneys do i have grounds for
appeal later based on improper
incompetent representation by council
because this is just going wrong for him
in absolutely every sense of the word
and there are
it is not completely implausible
that this could be the end of infowars
now if that's the case
i'm not going to
take pleasure in it from a personal
perspective but i do think it's
important to be able to have a
conversation about
is this entity a net positive or a net
negative for the world and for society
and there's a real question about that
to put it lightly to understate it
when it comes to infowars so we're going
to be watching all of this let's hope
that the january 6 committee does get
those texts why well because we should
know to what degree alex jones was
coordinating with people in trump's
circle so that's the latest there and
we'll do one more alex jones thing
before we move on
at the heart
of the entire alex jones defamation
trial and now the award phase and all of
the viral videos that we've been looking
at at the heart of all of this are the
original claims made by alex jones about
the sandy hook shooting a decade ago
and the central element of those claims
is that at one point alex jones said it
was all fake
it was a false flag orchestrated by
whoever the government them
um to create a pretext for the
confiscation of firearms
and a critical moment during this
defamation trial that we've been
watching this week
is when alex jones concedes that the
sandy hook attack was 100 percent real
now
does alex jones actually mean this
or is he saying it because now he has
been pushed into a corner and he
believes this is how you minimize the
damages that he will ultimately
be responsible for well let's take a
listen to the moment where this happened
to the end of 2014
we've had
a video received in evidence
of you stating
your belief at that time that
no one died at sandy hook that the whole
thing was fake
do you understand as you sit here today
how crazy that is
i have said before that
there have been so many lies and so many
things in the past and i was under a lot
of pressure and i truly when i said
those statements
when i say something i mean it
that i really could believe that it was
totally staged that point and i was
basing that off of
really steve mcgenick who is
has been a very prestigious person
do you understand even in getting to
saying that he now recognizes it was
real he's still defending why he thought
it was fake now that it was
absolutely irresponsible of you to do
that it was especially since i met the
parents and
um
it's 100 real as i said on the radio
yesterday
and as i said here yesterday
it's 100 real
and the media still ran with
lies that i was saying it wasn't real on
air yesterday it's incredible they won't
let me take it back they just want to
keep me in the position of being the
sandy hook man my son got confronted
yesterday objection speculation is what
the media wants mr jones is just saying
all right so now he goes off topic and
it's interrupted now do we believe alex
jones actually believes this now or is
this just a setup for some future
infowars exclusive about how the deep
state and the bilderbergs and the
dracula family forced alex jones to
apologize
or is it going to be well the attack was
real but everything leading up to it and
everything afterwards it's all part of
some larger conspiracy
i don't know
i don't know i'm not sure
whether
he is
genuinely
sorry for what he did and he believes
that it was wrong
empirically wrong
or that he's just upset that he's now
being held accountable i don't know the
answer to that but i'm curious to hear
from you one of the things that we've
been talking about is donald trump's
endorsement record donald trump and
others tout the power of the trump
endorsement and indeed donald trump over
the last 48 hours has been posting
uncontrollably
uncontrollably
to his uh platform truth social truth
essential and it is all about his
supposed endorsement record check this
out trump spending a lot of time there
trump candidates dominate tuesday's
primary elections
molly hemingway republicans need to
understand why its prospects are so good
trump reshaped the party he's the savior
as far as trump wants you to believe
trump 2024 crushed the establishment
retweeting all sorts of or re-truthing
all sorts of different stuff
trump-endorsed candidates are ready to
take back our country i guess quoting
carrie lake or who knows who blake
masters wins arizona republican senate
primary again the idea is thanks to
trump there
rusty bowers january 6th star witness
loses republican primary in arizona the
idea there is not a trump endorsed guy
and he lost
trump nod spurs dixon to runaway win in
michigan he's responsible there
trump backed gibbs this is the guy i
interviewed trump backed gibbs ousts
meyer in michigan republican race for
congress
um on and just if you scroll down truth
central it is just post after post after
post of donald trump taking credit for
all of these different victories trump
candidates dominate tuesday primaries
again
big historic win for trump endorsed
candidates across the country now 15-0
in senate primaries perfect records in
arizona kansas michigan and missouri
congratulations to our mag account this
i could just go and go and go i'm not
going to subject you to this not going
to subject you to this so
what is the truth about donald trump's
endorsement record well there's two
sides to this
one side of it are just the numbers like
are the numbers actually as good as
donald trump claims
and the second part would be
even if the numbers are as good as he
claims
are they meaningful are they
statistically significant when you
consider the circumstances let's go
through it one by one so first and
foremost ballot pedia maintains a page
the endorsements of donald trump
um during trump's presidency there were
305 endorsements since trump left office
there have been 237 additional
endorsements okay so
this year
trump's record
is 92 percent
that's a good record no question about
it
uh we'll get back to that in 2020
trump's endorsement record was 77
in 2019
it was 43 percent and those were special
elections in 2018 trump's record was 58
so let me explain to you what this is
all about all right
when donald trump was actually
making endorsements
uh
in uh general elections
where they were actually contested races
he was basically 50 50. so it's almost
like a coin flip okay if you consider
that trump endorsed some incumbents
there
and that uh trump made some endorsements
of individuals who were clearly the
favorite at the time of the endorsement
barely 50 50
isn't particularly impressive
it's just it's a little bit better than
a coin flip and a lot of the times he's
endorsing people who sort of like should
win anyway because they've raised the
most money they're the clear front
runners they're the incumbents so that's
number one
if you look at 2022
trump's record is significantly better
in the primaries because donald trump is
sometimes getting behind the obvious
leader
sometimes that's an incumbent and we
know about the power of incumbency uh
and sometimes trump is is waiting until
the absolute last moment and sometimes
it's very mushy like for example when he
endorsed eric in missouri and two if not
three of the leading candidates were
named eric like are we counting that as
a win i'm not sure whether that counts
here so
it's not a particularly interesting
endorsement story trump's endorsement
history is very 50 50
and then in particular in 2022 there's
this bias to just supporting the person
already likely to win now i will give
trump credit there are a handful of
candidates who were not winning when
trump endorsed them and then they ended
up winning and there's no doubt that
trump's endorsement has some power
the question is going to be
the general election the general
election in the general uh uh election
endorsements in 2022 trump is 0 for 10.
he's made 10 endorsements in general
elections where it's a democrat versus a
republican and he lost every single one
he doesn't talk about that
so we're going to pay attention to that
very closely as well we have a voicemail
number it's 2192 david p we haven't
heard much from eric from massachusetts
lately he's this coveted conspiracy
theorist who's been calling off calling
in off and on for the last two to three
years he's back and he's accusing me of
things that i never said
hey david it's there for mass um i get
the
idea that you're a frosting at the mouth
to have lockdowns and masks again when
did i say that
and have everybody be the economy be
crippled while you sit in your uh ivory
tower no i want the economy to do well
so my stocks and bonds go up and dictate
what everyone should do wrong um
you know like i told you i was a leftist
uh
democrat not no problem with
progressivism that why do you think i
found you
but uh when clover hit i knew they were
lying that's right this guy was a
progressive then all of a sudden there's
a virus and he becomes an unhinged
right-wing conspiracy theorist sounds
more like it's a mind virus that
infected them gonna do with politics
it's about lies and truths
you know what i mean and like you said
oh they're not gonna start something for
the midterms and then they said it what
will your excuse be now the midterms are
coming lockdowns are coming get the [ __ ]
out of here all right so anyway i don't
support any of that stuff i've said
nothing about it eric is very very
delusional and sometimes i think he's
reacting to things other hosts have said
like i think sometimes it's just he's
confused
we are going to talk on the bonus show
today about the lawsuit against the pga
for suspending golfers who played in the
saudi-funded golf tour we will talk
about josh hawley's vote against finland
and sweden joining nato and we will talk
about georgia residents being able to
claim embryos as dependents on state
taxes listen if nothing else they're
being consistent if that's a person
you should be able to claim an embryo as
a dependent i mean it it's at least
consistent
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show oh the bonus show where you
want to make money everybody else that
makes money to find themselves is bad
well alex i don't know that you're in a
position to really say much about the
bonus show right now you can sign up at
joinpackman.com
we will see you then